all right so I so I want to circle back
a little bit to the beginning of the
conversation and and your history and
your story for a second because you
identify as an atheist Muslim is that
correct well atheist Muslim is the title
of my book doctrinally I can't be an
atheist Muslim but the whole point of
the book is to talk about the
incorporation of religion into identity
so there are a lot of I mean with so
I'll explain it this way when I first
came here two years after I permanently
moved to permanently moved to Canada is
when 9/11 attacks happened and when that
happened I you know I had this whole
conversation
in my head you know as part of a Muslim
family I grew up with Muslim people I
did I was in all the Muslim traditions
the that Ramadan you know a lot of
things are cultural they're reasonably
cultural but there's some sort of Muslim
things like Ramadan so on into so that
was all a part of me but at the same
time I wasn't a huge fan of the ideology
so when I when I came here the 9/11
attacks happened this whole conversation
had been going on my head for very long
time
I suddenly exploded and was all you know
on TV was on the radio is everywhere and
there were two sides there was sort of
the liberal side and they said that you
know Muslims must be protected as a
minority so any criticism of Islam is
bigotry and on the right it was that and
this is the sort of the Fox News
narrative was that you know Islam is
sort of an it's a it's a it's a violent
religion so Muslims you know we need to
profile everybody you know we need to
clamp down on immigration and all of
those things and there was one mistake
both of them were doing is they were
conflating the ideology with the people
they're honing the ideology with the
identity and this and this is where I
wish for actually a middle ground and I
think what we're seeing we're seeing the
same thing with the regressive left on
one side and you know the the Donald
Trump phenomenon on the other is the
same thing as a conflation of this sort
of ideology and
people and by people I mean people who
are a Muslim Muslim just because it's as
a birthday identity because most people
are Muslim is a system right so for you
personally while you're obviously an
atheist so you're a non-believer do you
are you culturally Muslim like what does
that actually mean to you at this point
like I assume your family probably does
some holiday stuff maybe you don't
believe in it but do you culturally
identify that way me for example I'm an
atheist I am a not a believer but there
are Jewish traditions that my family
that my grandparents did that their
grandparents did that their grandparents
did that my family does so I can do that
and it doesn't have a religious
connotation it has a cultural
connotation to me that's it that's
exactly what it is I mean I enjoy I
enjoy the feast of Ramadan Ramadan is a
great time I mean you do you have people
frosting I don't necessarily fast but
I'm therefore that's a bit much yeah and
I like to eat celebrations I like you
know I have little nieces and nephews
and they all dress up and you know I get
them gifts and and so I enjoy that as
much as anybody I'm on you know I very
close to my family my nuclear family and
my extended family and a lot of them are
believing Muslims so I do take part in
that but there's also another place
where it affects you for instance I read
a story about this kid who was called
was beat up at school and because and
they said that you know she was an isis
baby or isis kid and my niece and I
don't want my niece to go through that I
know like this whole thing that's
happening in the u.s. right now you know
I don't want my and I've got I've got
nieces and nephews in the u.s. too and
you know so I don't want them to go
through that it would be completely
heartbreak I'd be devastated if I heard
that my own niece went through something
like that just because she has a Muslim
name you know a Muslim sounding name
mm-hmm she looks a certain way so it
affects you at that level too so when
things like that happen or you know I
recently I recently posted about this I
have a friend who's a physician yeah
he's and he actually he's in California
and he went to a party recently and
there's a woman who came up to him and
said you know you
she called him a Taliban terrorists and
so on and she was a little drunk and
unfortunately the people he was around
jumped in and you know they defended him
and they they called her out on it but
these are things that are having he's
also nathan's by the way so he's from a
Muslim background and you know so when
things like this happened this is
something that could happen to me as
well
if it happened to my own family so on
that level I do identify with the sort
of you know what a lot of Muslims are
going through on the other hand I also
get prejudice I mean I guess apostates
get it from not only the people who
target Muslims but the Muslims who
target us AIDS so it's a bit of a double
whammy there but you so you do relate to
it and this it's a very complicated
thing when you have that mixture of
ideology and identity yeah is it it's a
very complicated thing to navigate and
it's not as binary and as simple as you
know what you hear when you hear someone
like Glenn Greenwald talk about it or
someone like Donald Trump talk about do
I think are sort very similar yeah yeah
well that's why I phrased the question
the way I did because I don't see an
inherent contradiction there I think
that everything that you've described
sounds completely feasible to me and if
anything it's not just feasible
it sounds preferable to me because
you're taking the logical and the and
the secular side of your of your
existence and fully acknowledging that
and then also acknowledging your history
and your family and all that so that to
me that to me makes full sense and more
people should be trying to do that yeah
I think there is a Philip Zukerman is
this Jesus writer who wrote a book
called I think it's called living the
secular life yeah I'm pretty sure that's
what it's called in that he actually
talks about secularizing religion
himself and I he also did an interview
with sam harris sam harris interviewed
him for his blog and he talks about that
as a very sort of seminal step in moving
towards secularism is that you know you
take the holidays and take the rituals
you take the the community aspect of it
how they have sunday assemblies and
everything
so that those are examples of things
that people can do and out you know
religions actually moved toward
secularism and he talked about Reform
Judaism which was which is interesting
this you know Judaism and Islam again
very similar you know how God revealed
the Quran directly to Muhammad in the
same way God supposedly revealed the
Torah to to Moses at the tabernacle in
Mount Sinai and so on and it was
considered the literal word of God it
was actually considered the blueprint
for creation in Genesis at one point so
it was meant to even predate creation
and that's how it was thought of at a
time and then in the you know late late
eighteenth I think it was the it was the
19th century early 19th century when the
reformed Judaism movement really took
hold in it it got demoted from literal
word of God to divinely inspired yeah so
suddenly something was you know written
by the hands of human beings and
revelation became a progressive thing
you know it was a quality they adopt a
lot of secular values and so on and any
change so when people say well the Quran
is infallible you know how are you gonna
change it and I I always think they're
good the Quran there's precedent for
that there's actually precedent for that
with Judaism with because the
Catholicism for instance I mean there's
a lot of Catholics who are pro-choice a
lot of practice birth control many of
them they fornicate to their heart's
content but you know you if they still
go and they observe Lent and they
celebrate Christmas and Easter nobody
kicks him out of the church saying you
know you're not a Catholic yeah yeah
well for the record I told this to Peter
last week but I actually went to Mount
Sinai in 1997 I went to Egypt I went to
Sinai I hiked the mountain and literally
nothing happened I asked I mean I really
did I was at that place in life you know
20 or 21 or so or 19 and I I went there
trying to have something and talk to
somebody and and nobody nobody talked
back bad experience the first time you
don't want to repeat it again you don't
alright so I want to end with this
because you have brought up a phrase
that I think you've hashtagged and I
want to make sure that when this thing
takes off that
fully credited for it and hopefully I'll
have a little something to do with it
but you've talked about the new center
and I think it's it's the right phrase
for what we've been looking for I think
it fits it fits because we have this
left-right paradigm but it also fits the
center of this liberal split between you
know the regressives and the say classic
liberals so can you just tell me a
little bit more about what you think the
new center is and what we can all do to
get people there I say well it's
basically what I described here that you
know when you have that when it comes to
purely this aspect of Islamism and
jihadism and
sort of religious extremism if you say
even though that's a misnomer it's it's
about a separating ideology from
identity it's about being able to stand
up for the rights of people but at the
same time challenge ideas when you
attack and challenge ideas that's how
societies move forward if you attack and
debase people that's what splits people
up that's what actually rips us apart so
being able to do to make that
distinction is very important I don't
think either side is doing it and I
think that the center is more rational
and on a on a broader level - I have
always found it bizarre that you know if
you're fiscally conservative and then
you know you suddenly you have to be
pro-life right thank you why does all of
that go together I think it's absolutely
ridiculous people should be able to but
yeah you know how different you know I
should be able to think that okay I
believe needs to fiscally conservative
principles time I'm socially liberal or
I could have libertarian present there's
no rational I don't think you can be a
rationally thinking person and be
aligned with one side or the other yeah
well that's a whole other topic figuring
out how the the politicians figured out
to make everything a wedge issue so
somehow gay rights if you were for gay
rights
you were also for you know low taxes
like it just doesn't make any sense do
you think there's any chance for a
political movement with that because the
when I saw it you did hashtag NewsCenter
and I thought maybe there's politics
there not just not just this sort of
internal discussion that we'll all have
and hopefully get it out there more but
actually this could maybe be a political
movement I would lie with
like that that's why I brought up the
whole fiscally conservative socially
liberal thing is because yeah you know
when when I grew up you know on TV you
had the the six o'clock news and the 11
o'clock news and you know you saw
everybody watch that whether you're
liberal or conservative I'm in 1984 when
Ronald Reagan won I mean he won
California
he won 49 states out of 50 I'm not
endorsing Ronald Reagan or something
against him either
but I say is that things weren't as
polarized and then later on you had
24-hour cable news so you had Fox News
on one side and MSNBC on the other and
everybody just watched what their own
echo chamber was I mean every every
channel had its own echo chamber with
the blogosphere and with the internet
that became even more pronounced so
there's a lot of polarization and I
think it's getting to a point and we're
seeing this with the regressive lesson
left on the trumpian right you know I
think that there's that kind of
polarization is something that a lot of
reasonable rational people are not
feeling it's not working for them
they're actually frustrated by it and I
really hope that they do they're okay to
let go of the traditional left and right
labels because I they're practically
meaningless right now I don't think they
mean anything and I just be human beings
thinking human beings I love that
perfect ending and I love the fact that
we've connected and you'll always have
an ally over here so next time hopefully
we can do this in person when you make
it out to Los Angeles so I want to thank
alyre is B his book comes out next year
but in the meantime you can follow his
regressive smackdowns on Twitter thank
you guys for watching and we'll see you
next time